yeah peace i love peace  i'd be out of a job with peace  do we know each other  time  reality reality  [Music]  it's changeable  where you want to be  that's the question didn't it every  universe  is different each one  [Music]  slow down a little bit there's a few  people in the room that don't understand  not me i get it  who are you the name's captain carter  [Music]  i am the watcher i observe all that  transpires here  but i do not cannot will not interfere  i guess i have to freestyle then  hey we have you out of bird a ravager  never flies solo  i said never flies solo  ah is that some kind of catchphrase  you had me worried for a second  journey to face the unknown and ponder  the question  what if  you